[Musique]
une opération gratuite qui met en valeur
en fait le patrimoine culture le
patrimoine sculpture pardon on a des
animations qui vont s'organiser autour
de 22 sites partenaires donc il y en a
dix sept qui sont dans les
hauts-de-seine il y en a quatre dans le
78 on a le musée de la fondation convert
à saint rémy les chevreuse le musée de
saint quentin en yvelines la commanderie
à elancourt et le musée d'archéologie
nationale à saint germain en laye
[Musique]
c'est un travail de maillage en fait
territoriales pour que d'abord on aille
au devant de tous les publics sur ce
week end du 25 au 27 mars on puisse
et bien visiter et avoir un parcours
intéressant autour d'oeuvres sculpté il
va y avoir une chasse aux sculptures par
exemple qui va être organisée également
et qui va qui va sûrement beaucoup
intéressé les familles
il ya une programmation en ligne et ça
ça va permettre effectivement aux
habitants de nos deux départements de
pouvoir découvrir plus de cent
sculptures
autour de d'un certain nombre de
thématiques les animaux dans la
sculpture par exemple pour comprendre
que le plus facile sur le site du
printemps de la sculpture on aura
rendez-vous dans des musées de façon
virtuelle pour découvrir ou des
fondations ou des parcs sans bouger de
chez soi et bien on aura accès on aura
accès à ces sculptures et à ses oeuvres
qui sont disséminés dans sur le
territoire
[Musique]